[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
brett weinstein here welcome to the
first unity 2020 campfire
i apologize for the late start we had a
technical problem that had to be chased
down in order to make this work but it
looks like everything
is good to go i am here with dr
eric weinstein phd in mathematics
to talk about unity 2020. before we get
to the discussion though i just want to
say a brief word about why we have
chosen campfire as a metaphor
and what it means to you and to us
so the idea here is that our ancestors
have faced different kinds of times
they've faced times when things were
good and they knew what to do and around
the campfire they would have celebrated
they would have joked they would have
danced
and then in other times when they were
unable to figure out what needed to be
done
because something had changed or they
had entered a new landscape with
different rules they had to figure out
what to do
and what they would have done is
partnered around the campfire and they
would have talked about the problem
they would have parallel processed it
processed it by plugging their minds
into each other
by talking just as we are doing here and
will do
going forward so what we have here is a
setup
where eric and i are going to kick off
the conversation for something like
an hour we're going to talk about the
questions surrounding unity 2020
get his perspective on what we might be
doing differently and how we should
go forward we also have a technical back
end that is going to allow
i believe the first thousand people who
came through the door
this evening to give us feedback they
will be able to pose questions
most of which will be in the second part
of this discussion
and we will be able to pose questions to
them and we have noah who you won't be
able to see but we'll be able to hear
and he will be able to convey your
answers to us so that we can
use them as fodder for further
discussion
so without further ado eric welcome to
the first unity 2020 campfire
it's uh it's an amazing honor to be here
i brought my guitar
and i'm disappointed that there are no
s'mores so for campfire number two i
know what we need to do next
yes i uh i agree with you that s'mores
would be delightful although they would
have to be gluten free
all right so eric you have been watching
and participating in discussions
surrounding unity 2020
since the beginning obviously
you and i are of like mind anybody who
follows either you
or me will know that we perceive
uh desperate times ahead for the
republic if we do not figure out how to
rescue ourselves
from the predicament that the duopoly
has
placed us in i guess there are also
differences in the way we see things and
hopefully they will
emerge in this conversation but
do you want to say something about where
you think we might be in history
and what the various paths forward might
look like
uh well i can try i can say that we are
suffering from something that doesn't
make a lot of
sense at an a priori level whatever's
going on is super subtle
because people are apparently so angry
and so mad
about so many things that they're
willing to destroy the republic without
going through the
courtesy process of trying to save it in
the meantime
and i don't quite know how people expect
the republic
to operate when we're speaking about the
u.s and this is a u.s based conversation
because it requires a culture and the
culture that goes with the documents
is an essential part of running the
american culture
so if you repudiate everything that is
american just decide that we are some
sort of outgrowth of colonialism
oppression
and every terrible thing under the sun
from the left of center
perspective or you decide that in some
sense that the country
needs to go backwards into some imagined
uh era when it was great and everything
was working fine which has never been
the case
um both of those perspectives uh
are not really american perspectives we
are a country that has built up a uh
an advantage for our people militarily
the world depends on our protection and
it has to do with a
cumulative process of trying to be right
more than we're wrong
because every nation is wrong plenty and
when you're dealing with anything like
the united states everything that we do
is amplified the good that we do is
amplified the bad that we do is
amplified
and the most important thing is that
most of america still remembers what it
means to be american
whether on the left or the right but
they cannot figure out how to ground
that in their political parties their
universities
their newspapers and news desks
and so we're very confused as to
why every institution is failing us when
so many of us remember what it is that
we're supposed to be doing which is
getting back to
uh you know kicking ass and providing
for the planet
and trying to do a better job of
figuring out what a vibrant
multicultural
superpower is supposed to be in terms of
being more decent humane and good
stewards and
for whatever reason too many people have
lost the plot
of the american story so those of us who
remember that plot and want to see it
through for many more chapters are very
frustrated so
that's sort of where we begin i think
both you and i perceive
that the necessity of doing something is
very high
because even though it doesn't make full
sense as to why we're in such desperate
straits
something has clearly gone wrong or you
wouldn't have the kind of
bizarre discussion and dialogue as you
see
in the pages of the new york times and
the washington post
fox the two political parties it's just
we're watching garbage and nonsense
traded around by a group of insiders
while most of us
sit around wondering what we're doing
stuck in the back seat while mommy and
daddy run the car
completely off the road on some sort of
drunken weekend that never ends
so i want to unpack a little bit what
some of the different failure modes that
are combining
into this catastrophe look like at least
to me
um so you have talked extensively and
you've been
laser focused for a long time on the
failure of institutions
right you basically see a failure across
all of the important institutions that
would
either help us make sense or help us
navigate and i agree
possible exception of trader joe's which
is fighting back
yes trader joe's does does show signs of
life and
trader jose is uh i will be buying all
of the trader jose
products in part because i know that my
hispanic american friends
do not think that this is something
worth getting upset about right
i mean frankly i'm upset about those uh
yellow
taco shells that we were led to believe
had something to do with mexican
cuisine but that's a story for another
time so institutions
aside from possibly trader joe's seem to
be
in some kind of delusional phase where
things are clearly collapsing within and
around them
and they're not acknowledging it and
they're pretending everything is normal
and maybe that's the most normal failure
i see
the second one though is i see a lot of
people
who you alluded to who are enamored of
the idea that something is so
wrong that the only choice we have is to
tear this all down
and start over or tear it down such that
something
will naturally flourish in its place and
i find this a a
shocking kind of failure of
understanding because
we see the things that don't work pretty
easily but we don't see the things that
do work
precisely because they do and so if you
compare
the question of whether we should take
the experiment
and we should finally finish it in other
words if you
look at the civil rights era for example
and then you
imagine that we might complete the job
that's one choice
or we could reverse course and we could
go back to things like
segregation and a race-first view of
humanity
and to me it's obvious that there is no
comparison between these obviously
completing the job is
vastly more plausible and uh stands a
chance of leaving a decent world in its
wake
i think we've we've failed to understand
exactly why so few people want to see
this thing through
and i think it has to do with the
hollowing out of what would have been
called the center
um because of the
the the problem with language here we
have a kleptocratic
group that used to be the establishment
that we would count upon to
you know hand power back and forth when
we were
up against a cold war enemy in the
soviet union for example
and a lot of the people who would have
been the adults in the room became
kleptocrats
and so there's no way to point to what
it is that we think about when we say
we want to see the project through
because what do you mean by that do you
mean
i would have wanted to see the southern
poverty law center get more powerful
in its old incarnation i do not want to
see the southern poverty law center get
more powerful in its witch-hunting
incarnation
i would want to see um
you know the university um well my
university
university of pennsylvania harvard
princeton get more powerful i'm now very
worried that they
no longer hold liberal values uh
and i don't mean lefty values i mean you
know tolerant values
i i would have wanted to see
um a strong conservative movement even
though i'm not a conservative because
they
are in charge of making sure we don't go
too fast too quickly into nonsense
i don't see the party that's capable of
retarding that so all of these
structures
um i think we've lost faith in the
institutional instantiation of the
american
project and that's that's the key
problem which is when people
will will then point and they'll say
well are you saying we should go back to
the clintons in the bushes
and you know i can join with the
farthest of the far
left and the far right and saying hell
no right that's the only thing i may
join with the farthest of the far left
and the far right but
yeah i'm equally opposed to the clintons
and the bushes and all that crap
that's clogging the arteries of the
american project
now the issue of whether we are going to
retain a culture one of the great things
about living in a country which is
founded
by an actual patriarchy like there's
very little in which the word patriarchy
actually makes sense
actually the us was actually founded as
a patriarchy and the brilliance
of it is is that those guys figured out
how to get rid of their own badness in a
weird way
so you know we have after a long period
of time a nauseating history with
slavery
abolished a nauseating history with
women not having the vote
you know started in places like wyoming
that got
sorted out we've made great strides in
the civil rights era
are we done not by a long shot are we
have we done like an enormous amount of
the work you bet
and this idea that we are so much worse
off today
i think is it's an illusion in part
because a lot of people are afraid
that we've made enough progress that a
lot of people are going to lose interest
in the various projects that we have to
complete
and so they're amping things up and
saying that things are worse than
they've ever been
and i think you know where we have to go
is that we have
to lead the charge against the center
not because we're against centrism or
moderation
or you know grown-up-ness but because
those people
aren't grown-ups they are kleptocrats
and the kleptocrats have hollowed this
thing out
and so we have nothing to point to uh to
say institutionally what is the american
project i think that's where we are what
do you think
well a couple things one i'm going to
take exception to
your portrayal of the founders as um
patriarchal
i think it's more patrilineal but we'll
save that for a podcast sometime it's
worth unpacking
um the key difference i just wanted to
make the point that a bunch of a bunch
of dudes
who were relatively similar laid the
groundwork for a society of
dudes and non-dudes of all colors of the
rainbow
and it may have taken too long to get
there but the fact that they didn't bake
in a bunch of stuff that made that
impossible
shows you what a genius project this is
and to try to tie everything back to
1619 or 1776 or 1860
i mean i just don't even know what we're
doing yeah it was a genius prototype is
the way i see it and it's no shock it's
actually amazing how long it lasted
given how much
change the period of time over which one
hell of a startup yeah
nicely said so here's the thing that i'm
running into very frequently now which i
think is probably
closer to where we should focus i run
into people
who very clearly see one
of two catastrophes there's a
catastrophe that involves the ascendancy
of joe
biden who will have partnered with
the blm movement and that this will
actually
cause the undoing of all of the
structures on which we depend i know
many people who see that clearly
and i see an equal number of people who
are very clear on
the threat of having trump remain
in office and my sense is both of these
are very dangerous scenarios
that much is clear if you're able to
track what will happen in either case
but because people tend to see one at
the exclusion of the other we're having
a very
odd conversation about the election
which is if you realize that the system
that is made up of these two parties has
delivered us
basically a pair of catastrophic modes
where the the catastrophic risks are
just all too apparent
then the question is well if ever there
was a moment
that we need to challenge that structure
and step
outside of it this would be that moment
it's absolutely clear
so the question though is in a world of
people who more often than not
see one of two failures but have a blind
spot that covers the other
what do those of us who see both
failures do
in order to bring people into the
unfortunately
frightening discovery of where we
actually seem to be
it's a good question um i think in a
large measure we've lost
track of where everyone's mind is
because
our minds are increasingly not subject
to any particular input in general or in
common
uh one thing that we learned for example
is that a lot of people
inside the news industry who hired
fairly radical
journalists were very late to see the
problem because they somehow had an
immunity
and when they lost that immunity and
they started seeing their own kind fired
we got the harper's letter
right so in fact the issue is what is
proximate to you
try to imagine two separate nightmares
one nightmare
of you know a return to some sort of
ethnonationalism where america is for
the americans go home if you don't like
it blah blah blah
that's a pretty ugly country i wouldn't
want to live in it
on the other hand i wouldn't want to
live
in a country that can't stand up to
people saying abolish the police
and i'm not going to live in a country
in which one particular
um you know identity classification is
told that it has rights over everyone
else whatever that is doesn't it can be
any particular thing could be
on the left you know trans female black
even the way in which these things are
now interfering with each other
so this abandonment of the martin luther
king
kind of project is something that's
particularly distressing to some
some of our black friends we're like
wait a minute i i bought into that whole
thing about getting beyond this
and now i'm hearing that we can't so i
think in part people are very
guilty and because they're feeling
extremely guilty
about all of the things that they know
that they've done wrong in their lives
they're weirdly both defensive and
overly eager to placate
um so you see the sort of madness where
people are both
self-righteously you know exempting
themselves and they're also falling over
backwards
i i bet that there are even some people
who are called karen's
who are insisting on you know the
whitest of their white privilege
the same time as they're falling over to
say black lives matter you know and i
think
we just heard about uh possibly somebody
being
injured or killed who said all lives
matter you know
so we're getting into something where
many people are amped up
we're seeing portland and seattle and it
doesn't make any sense we're seeing the
cruelty
of trump's very calculated
tweets and utterances which are intended
to sound like dog whistles to get lots
of people to bite
and then you know the right will will
laugh at them
and say ha ha he didn't say that you
know
it's ugly stuff and it's not
where obama's substance was pointed in
term
sorry where obama's optics were pointed
in terms of substance
was a pretty terrific place and if his
substance had gone along with his optics
that would have been an amazing
presidency but
what we're looking for clearly is a very
mature
um leader who
grasps our current moment and by
listening
becomes the speaker but you have to
listen to the american people first and
we're upset and we're upset because our
genie coefficient is through the roof
our inequality is obnoxious and
as a guy who has been tracking all of
the power moves we've been making since
the reagan administration
to screw over our own people
that's a very disconcerting place to be
for me
which is that i've been looking at all
the ways that we've been led to the
slaughter
and we went along with these people and
now we're angry because we don't know
who picked our pocket we can't hire an
accountant or a lawyer to go get
you know our future back and
to your point brett i don't understand
why people are only angry
at one side or the other
i i'm very much with mercutio here a
plague on both your houses
i mean who the hell who the hell elected
either one of these parties
willingly i'd get rid of both of them if
i could
um but again it's it's not the parties
that are the
problem it's the inhabitants it's it's
the current
sort of thought tribe that inhabits both
of them that's focused on extracting
from the us
rather than growing the us pie
well i think it uh goes to a point that
you've been making for years that this
is
effectively something that has taken
over the shell of another creature it's
a hermit crab
that the dnc is in no way part of the
democratic party that was once dedicated
to the interests of
working people it's something that has
previous that
people previously known as uh you know
working class
now known as the deplorables and right
the the the concept of a deplorable is a
democratic apostate and the idea that
we're turning our back
on people uh who don't eat the same
finger sandwiches
that we do on the coasts in the middle
of the country is ugly and preposterous
and it's in the worst traditions
of american elitism so
we need to get to some brass tacks here
but let me just uh
say that in the last couple of days i
think we've seen
some indications that um
the democratic party has played a hand
that it cannot
finish that um there are indications
the new york times floated a trial
balloon about killing off
presidential debates on the basis that
they are putilistic and
not productive and while i think all of
us who
would care to see some honest
disagreement between
um candidates you know sort of lincoln
douglas style or something
a lot of us are tired of these
mind-numbing debates but the idea that
maybe we should cancel these debates at
a time when one of the candidates
very much looks like he might be
revealed
as incapable of inhabiting the office
uh that's an ominous sign and then to
hear today
i think i think you i know which one
well i think uh frankly they both show
signs but one of them shows them a lot
more regularly well one of them has
showed those signs
through almost a full term in office
and they may have gotten a little bit
worse and a bit more troubling
but i think that the absence of joe
biden from the campaign trail
is terrifying and the idea that the new
york times just happens to find
the debate format vacuous at a time that
we haven't seen biden
i mean good god which
uh cognitively impaired child is this
intended to fool i just don't understand
right i mean even in the best of
circumstances even if we were talking
about
you know bernie sanders who i think
doesn't show any signs
of such decline he's still old enough
that they could creep in
very rapidly and so you would have to
worry about that but
you're talking about a full decade older
than the oldest
president ever to take an initial oath
of office
in bernie sanders the entire concept
that our final five
candidates uh who is what biden
bloomberg trump uh
warren um who am i missing
you didn't get fired sanders everyone
was born in the 1940s
i mean cut it out for god's sakes you
have
you have a country full of vibrant
people we've spent
20 years exploring presidents who were
born
in the summer of 1946 at the very
beginning of the baby boom
it's effing enough and and these people
are all
old by presidential standards
and they're not
k i mean these are people who don't code
these are people who don't intuit
the modern landscape joe biden was first
elected to the senate
in at the age of 29 in 1972.
donald trump has no real
standard business experience that we
know of everything he does is
bizarre and non-standard
we are in a situation where we've got a
very dire
problem with china which we're supposed
to be focused on we've got to restart
our economic situation so that we can
have a growth pattern that can support
all of the obligations we've taken on we
we should be using this time to make the
world a safer place
both from the point of view of climate
and um nuclear weapons
the covet thing we don't even know where
this thing came from because everyone's
lying about it nobody trusts any
institution
i think we need to get bret to why i'm
agreeing to do this
call and why i am coming
around which is very rare in our
relationship
i noticed i'm coming around to see your
perspective a lot more
as a a lot more forward thinking than i
was
and so if i'm going to suffer through
some indignity here i'd like to get it
over with
all right let's let's get right to that
okay
um so so i thought you were going to
launch into the indignity um
[Music]
do we need a struggle session is that
what it is
um do that offline right i think i think
what we need to do is we need to
discuss my changing attitudes towards
unity 2020
um in part what i what i see you guys as
doing and why it is not the crazy
move that i probably initially viewed it
as being
um and so i'm open to it
and then the floor is yours so i think
what i remember you saying previously at
the beginning
um at the beginning of unity 2020 what
you said was that you regarded it
as crazy which didn't mean that it was
wrong which i found an interesting
formulation but anyway you've uh you've
moved from there and i think
uh the the parties have helped they've
revealed a little bit more
of uh just how um shallow their plan for
us all
is uh so
all right as i see it there is
um no chance that we should allow this
opportunity to pass without at least
trying to disrupt the uh the paired
failure modes that the major parties
have delivered us because the danger is
too great in fact
while i think one would have to regard
the likelihood that the republic
survives to 2024 i don't think in this
circumstance it would be
fair to call that uh safe
the dane the things are moving too
rapidly in a direction
in a particularly dire direction where
the far right
and the far left both have too much
power and they seem
to agree on a race first
mode of interaction which is
unfortunately probably the default mode
in humans and so in some sense dragging
us back to that isn't so hard
and resisting that urge and completing
the experiment
in which the founders set something in
motion where we might collaborate on
some basis other than race
is uh the obvious direction uh the
trajectory that we should remain on
so all right what has uh changed your
perspective of
the wisdom of attempting such a thing
this time
well okay so if i'm going to admit um if
i'm going to admit that i've changed my
mind a bit
i i want to be self-kind and doing it
here's what i'm really feeling brett i
keep asking this question what the hell
is wrong with everybody
why is no one doing anything this is
learned helplessness marty seligman's
theory from
years ago and it says that if you've
been treated
to a situation in which you can't
actually do anything to save yourself
once those constraints that kept you
from acting in a self-beneficial way
are removed you may not try to save
yourself because you've learned
in fact how to be helpless and how not
to to move
and so i've been i don't usually suffer
from learned helplessness particularly
i'd like to be agentic but i was
wandering around talking to smart people
who were
powerful who you know probably have
their
fingers closer to the levers of power
than either one of us
and none of them are doing anything none
of them are doing anything they are
standing back
and saying wow it's really terrible
and those with money are trying to
figure out where they can move
where can we go as opposed to how do we
deploy capital in order to try to
fix this and those in a political
situation where they can actually get
something to
to happen have this idea of look there's
gridlock nothing can work
you guys are children you don't
understand why the system can't work
which is probably right they probably do
know that
in fact nothing can work and then when
you look at you know the universities
and the academicians and the writers and
the commentariat
they're saying you know you have to
understand that people are simple-minded
they can only
perturb around what they know we can't
really take any flights
away from this duopoly and then i
started
thinking about it okay the one person
who isn't afflicted by learned
helplessness in this situation is brett
and that was tough it was a tough
recognition
that the guy was calling me up and
saying what would it take no i've
answered that issue
three calls ago what is it that you're
really upset about
it took me a while to sort of recognize
that
in fact my complaints about your
charging off into unity 2020
which is you don't realize how much
capital that can chew up
you don't understand exactly um
what being enmeshed in the political
process does to expose you
to um harm from deeply entrenched
interests
all of those issues have to do with my
worry that i don't want to spend our
capital it's not i'm not
trying to be a [ __ ] about it i'm trying
to say i'm very concerned that when we
have the right opportunity
i want to make sure we have the dry
powder needed
to use it and i think that that has not
gone away
i still feel that way what we have is an
absolute necessity to do something
and we have the fact that it probably is
going to require this is a bitter pill
that you and i have talked about
it is probably going to require the
arrival of
some kind of good luck for us to be able
to do something to get out of here
something exogenous happens
you know can you imagine for example if
you had a terrible cognitive performance
of both a trump and abiden in a debate
and it became clear that
neither of these people should be
anywhere close to the oval office
that's the situation that people who
were anticipating
a collapse in the stock market in the
1920s were in where they were writing up
things and everybody was saying this is
stupid the stock market is doing great
and then when the crash finally happened
the only people that you could turn to
were the people who actually hadn't had
learned helplessness during the 20s
so this is a crazy proposal to my
earlier point
and the typical way of saying it comes
from physics which is we are all in
agreement that your
theory is crazy what divides us is
whether it is crazy enough and that's
you know a beautifully stated couplet
that's not my issue
you're crazy enough the issue is you
need luck
and it's clearly what we need and so my
view of what unity 2020
is is quite honestly that the people who
recognize
how serious the situation is and who are
tired of fighting with each other
are waiting for some thing to break that
is not
foreseen and that thing is going to look
for a home
and there's going to be no home for it
because the the republican party the
democratic party are hostile
to anything that isn't kleptocratic
and that means that you have to build
something like an ark
before it starts raining okay
now that wasn't where you that wasn't
where we were divided either
what i'm starting to realize is that i
can afford to do something different
i can afford to point to this and when
somebody says oh well brett said it was
going to be unity 20 20. i'm going to
say no
listen to me brett wasn't suffering from
learned helplessness
and it's one of these things where uh if
you don't use it you're going to lose it
if you don't use your sense of agency
you know i make fun of elon for building
rockets to go to mars because there's
nothing up there and it's not going to
happen and we're not going to terraform
it he's not going to colonize mars and
all that stuff
but you know what for whatever reason
the guy is still building rockets
and he's still ferrying people to space
and you know something
if somebody else breaks the laws of
physics
and they need something to some
engineer to create something so we can
do it you know
interstellar travel i bet the guy who's
building rockets now is gonna drop
rockets like a hot potato okay i think
brett what you're doing
is is that you're saying you know what
i'm gonna get out here
and i'm going to build an effing arc and
i'm going to try to do something that
doesn't exhibit learned helplessness and
if you want to make fun of me and you
want to say that i was
unrealistic and i was idealistic and all
that stupid stuff and then you're going
to go home and listen to imagine by john
lennon and cry
a few tears not putting together in fact
that
we we've got to do idealistic things
because we're an idealistic nation this
place
runs on idealism even though we know
better
even though we know all the horrible
things the u.s has done that it pretends
that it didn't
okay it did do a lot of stuff but you
know what not only were the
we the nation of milai we were also the
nation that uncovered milai and
publicized milai and we did the same
thing with abu ghraib and we did the
same thing with the church and pike
committees
and you know brett they came after our
family in particular
and we're the same country that in fact
repudiated mccarthyism
repudiated it and just as you and i are
repudiating what i've called left car
theism so what is it that you're doing
what you're actually doing is saying you
know what
you guys it's like putting on a mask in
a culture where nobody wears a face mask
somebody's got to do something that
looks weird
and it's agentic and it's actually what
unity 2020 is
it's the cult of people who refuse to
subscribe and
succumb to learned helplessness which is
now being doled out with
with with the mother's milk for our new
crop of
people coming out and so that's what i'm
i've changed my mind about which is that
i realized that you were actually
exhibiting
a fight against learned helplessness in
your actions
and i'm 100 supportive of that
so is this my fight uh i don't think i
would have chosen this particular battle
but i think that the point is is that
all you are is
one crazy piece of luck away from this
really being something and i don't know
that you can script it
but boy would it be a great thing to
have a boat
when the when you start to see more rain
than anybody's ever seen and i think
that's where we are
well thank you for that and i agree with
you about block this has been on my mind
from the beginning is that 2020 is such
a an unpredictable year that
the unexpected has to be expected in
some sense
and i think we're we're seeing it
now the question is when i hear people
feeling clever for finding reasons not
to listen to something
like unity 2020 you know finding reasons
to go back to sleep effectively
i'm not sure i have a hard time
understanding their mindset
in fact i was talking to john wood jr
this morning
and um i was making the point that the
republic is in jeopardy and that is
exactly the kind of thing
that people used to have to put their
life on the line to prevent
right and people frequently talk about
the kind of patriotism
that would cause you to lay down your
life for something
bigger than yourself and what he said
was
yes that people
who once might have laid down their
lives
are won't even do it when the risk is
being disliked
and i really do feel that that's where
we are that in some sense
we are lucky that the you know
the the out of left field plan to do
something
doesn't involve risk to life and limb it
involves risk to reputation but um
i guess the question i have for you is
how can we get people who are feeling
clever for seeing reasons
not to think outside the box how can we
get them to understand
that the reality is actually flipped on
its head
that um in some sense you are
foolish that learned helplessness is
going to get you killed
and thinking outside the box is really
where where
hope uh resides
well i think that the first thing you do
is that you stop trying to fight them
you confirm what they're trying to say
yeah you might look foolish
i mean look there's no major party here
and when was the last time anything like
this worked right so absolutely if your
major
goal in life is never to look like
you've been taken in
never to feel like oh my god i got
bamboozled or i got suckered in or i
started to believe in something
congratulations because that's what
they'll put on your tune soon
never fell in love never believed in a
cause
never got seduced never
lost themselves in a film and and uh and
allowed themselves to believe and to be
transported
okay you got bigger problems at this
moment
um because if what you're trying to do
is to die with never got fooled on your
tombstone
i don't even know you i just don't even
know you now the question is we don't
want to be seduced by everyone
or everything and you don't want to be
seduced by a movement that's not
serious key point is this is exactly
how the us came to be
there were a bunch of crazy people the
cuban revolution was launched
the paper of cuba was the name the
grandma because fidel castro
sailed on a boat called the grandma it
was a bunch of ragtag
people i mean you can be pretty
unenthusiastic about fidel castro
and still say yeah it was a bad idea to
bet against
the scraggly uh you know deadbeats out
playing war out in the bushes um
it revolutions need be neither good nor
bad
so the first question is do you believe
we are in revolutionary times
do you believe that a single death like
george floyd's could cause millions of
people to go out in the street
completely unsure of exactly what that
video meant because it optically looked
like a lynching to be blunt about it
that's the kind of a place that we are
in we are in a place where people are
filled with
fear they're filled with uncertainty um
are you the sort of a person who ever
thought you would see
mayors stepping away from policing
duties i mean that's terrifying what
happened with chaz
completely completely understandable
all of those weird things let you know
that we are in
incredible times and neither party has
the answers none of the universities
everybody's running scared so in some
sense the most american
thing to do
is to man or woman up or
other doesn't matter just you know i i
use the word huevos because it works
both
for both genders it requires courage
this is a moment that requires huevos
and if you don't have them then
don't bad mouth the people who do
because
they're the people who built your
country everything about this place
came from the middle finger
came from the inguinal regions and
that's part of the american project
and if all you're here to do is to you
know pick up your check
and cache it and enjoy your barbecues in
your backyard you're not part of the
mainstream of the project it's a much
more dangerous and daring thing to do
the other thing about reputation is
don't kid yourself this can get you
killed just fine
this is actually dangerous and if you if
you're going to risk your life for a
gopro video while you're snowboarding
you know or or you're going to jump off
some rock while you're
on vacation at least risk your life for
something the key issue though
is is anyone in the future going to
appreciate this
and that's kind of the thing i look at
albert einstein for example during the
mccarthy era
he was hated martin luther king was
hated by many people during his life
the key point is the people who are
going to appreciate you now
are going to be few in number what we're
doing this for is our is our own
grandchildren
and i think this is one of the biggest
problems with the silent generation
and the the boomer generations is that
they are bizarrely unconcerned with
their own
with their own children and
grandchildren and quite honestly you and
i brett are
gen x and i love their children more
than they love their children
and i love their grandchildren more than
they love their their grandchildren i
don't know what that's about
but i'll tell you one thing we you and i
have four gen
z kids there's no effing way i'm
stepping
aside and letting these two generations
that do not know how to govern or lead
have at my kid's generation it's it's
it's enough those
kids you know my daughter is just
signing up to vote because she's going
to turn 18
this month we've got to recognize
that the thank yous
are going to come privately because
everyone's too scared so they're going
to be tons of thank yous for people who
sign on to these things
and they're going to come after we get
some real wins and
sooner or later we're going to get a
shot across the bow which is going to be
the weird piece of luck and the key
question is does it hit the bow and the
ship
sinks or does it get over the bow and
then we're going to look around
like is there anybody who's been telling
us that this is a disaster one thing you
and i brett have seen for example
with the harper's letter is is that we
had a bunch of people coming from the
commentary
that say oh my god you guys were right
about everything and that was a very
weird thing
we said well why didn't you understand
at the time
they said oh we thought it was just
about university campuses and that's
what fox news and tucker carlson always
talks about with campus craziness
but now that we see that it's everywhere
and it's not going to stop and it's in
your politics and it's in your science
my god this this stuff is in your
science you're all your science is going
to be screwed up
this is a romantic thing to do and i
want to say that when i
saw your situation at evergreen where
you were doing what you've always done
which is to stand against racism
and even when it comes from people who
have historically had racism focused on
them
black americans right when you stood up
for that
i had this really big question which is
what was my
place in that and what i said was that
standing shoulder to shoulder
with you was a thrill and it's a thrill
to be
part of something that is fighting on
behalf of something larger there's
clearly no economic incentive in this
because mostly it's just going to get
you laughed off the face of the map
which is one way of knowing that
everybody here is ultra serious about
the democratic
process um we want to return to
to normal so i think what you need to do
is you need to level with them yep
it's probably not going to work it is
dangerous you'll get laughed at
for sure but you're also going to meet
people you'd never meet otherwise
and if anything works because we get a
piece of luck and we're actually able to
make this thing
sing people are going to thank you and
they're going to want to know where
why was the group of people so small and
the answer is it was always
the smallest groups of people because
they're the ones who are not
tracking garbage reality and that the
most of what you have fed into your
brain
from the moment you wake up to the
moment you go to bed at night is garbage
reality it's
not real reality it's just garbage that
people are filling your head with so you
don't
act yeah well i agree with a lot of that
and i resonate
uh with it you know i think for me one
of the things that i
fear is that you listen to those voices
and then the storm comes and you don't
have the damn boat
right and so i fear that much more than
being
left out for for doing something so
maybe maybe this is an exercise brett
maybe
somebody on your team should go to
all of the silly people um who were
talking about the financial crash before
the financial crash
and all of the voices like record all of
the voices that said
donald trump is not going to be your
next president
or kovid please the flu is a much bigger
deal
you know well actually whatever we have
that artifact
i would just say if you want homework
watch the big short and the people who
made that film
did it very unity 2020 needs to make its
own film there's some filmmaker out
there who wants to help
and that person needs to put together a
pastiche
of all of the smart sophisticated people
and organs like somebody did this called
something like in the hall of the trump
and king
which was all of the liberal talking
heads
saying donald trump will never be
president of the united states you can
take that to the bank
and everybody from you know i don't know
who was it stephen colbert
or um any of the the standard talking
heads
they all look ridiculous obama you know
made the point that he'll never be
president of the united states
now the key point is do you want to go
down with
that with that clown car because the
clown car is going to tell you
that this is ridiculous so start making
fun of the clown car
because the clown car didn't guess the
2016 election it didn't guess the 2008
financial
crisis it gets nothing right yep
okay so um i agree with that there is
this
people have the wrong reaction uh to
being laughed at and the point is
there's a gate
towards that that
that gets you to the position of being
regarded as far-sighted and it involves
a period of
being regarded as foolish and if people
understood that yeah you're gonna you're
gonna lose people but that the people
you meet by doing it
uh will be a very high quality which i
guarantee you is true
i can't tell you how many really
interesting patriots
unity 2020 has just brought out of the
woodwork right so
i could spend all day every day on calls
with really
dynamic interesting patriots because
they exist it's not a high percentage
but it's a large number well i think
there are a lot of latent patriots
i think that we represent a majority of
americans who do not know
where to turn to get back to being
americans i don't think that's a small
group
i think that the group of agentic people
are like what's the next step brett
you know it's very tough for me because
i'm your older brother and quite
honestly i'll never take a back seat to
you except if
if it warrants it and in this situation
i think that you are more right than i
am
in a certain way which is that
i don't think the fact that this is
unlikely to work in my estimation
is the most important thing i think the
most important thing is that we get back
to agency and that we swing at pitches
rather than trying to figure out how to
walk to first base
which is what we usually do it's time to
actually start swinging at pitches and
trying to remember what a home run feels
like
well and the and the answer is if you
strike out
but you're trying to connect with the
ball i understand why it was i came to
the game nobody goes to a baseball game
hoping to watch everybody walk yeah
so i would say best case
we get lucky we swing we knock it out of
the park
but the fallback position i would say is
that
um unity is if we fail here
unity becomes a concept and basically it
exists
meaningfully until we succeed i want to
talk about two words that are important
to me if we're going to talk about this
okay
unity 2024 and unity 2028.
right and the the issue is is that every
time we come up with an election it's
always
make or break it's always dire the court
is on the line we cannot
afford right every time so i can set my
clock to the fact that in
2024 i'm gonna have the same
set of pressures you can't do that eric
you don't understand what this is about
2028 same thing 2032. if we get to those
numbers
it will never be the right time to break
out of the kleptocracy agreement between
the two parties i called the
democratic party and the republican
party together the looting party
the looting party until we actually
restore
both of these parties and we get
patriotic conservatives and patriotic
democrats i mean basically what we're
talking about is something like occupied
france
and i don't want to pretend that i'm not
french uh
if i'm charles de gaulle and i'm sitting
in london i just want to get these vichy
guys
the hell out of there because that's not
my country it's the right shell
the same language the food is good the
key point we're not behaving like
frenchmen well we're not behaving like
democrats
and they're not behaving like
republicans and so whatever this thing
is
unity 2024 and unity 2028
need to be thought through now this
needs to be the problem that will not go
away no we won't shut up
no we won't go sit in our corner no we
won't let the adults sort it out
because frankly you're not adults well
just look at
the other way to do it is to remember
who the prior
greater evils were that we were told we
couldn't possibly risk
confronting the duopoly because we would
empower the
the worst of them you know i mean mitt
romney was
the great evil we couldn't risk that
it's hilarious now but
uh okay so let's uh try to bring people
in a little bit we we are still learning
to use the tools at our disposal
um noah you're gonna have to help us
figure out how to do this but i'm i'm
wondering how people
actually feel about the question
of whether or not this
is a moment of revolutionary magnitude
in other words is this a moment as
serious as all of those events that we
could put on
that list or is it not and
i guess i would like a second question
um
if it were such a moment do you believe
that if this
required valor on a battlefield that
you could find it in yourself or do you
believe that something about us has
changed that would make that
impossible that the things that people
once laid down their lives for that
that's somehow
a passe concept eric is there anything
you want to add to the
list of questions that we might solicit
answers to
it's an interesting uh puzzle i guess
the key thing
that i would be thinking about is um
what is your threshold like at the
moment i'm still holding back
a bit because i don't see that
we have the missing catalyst in place
um but i'm very happy that you're not
holding back
what is it that you what give a fantasy
about what it what could happen that
would allow you
to go whole hog full-throated volunteer
for unity 2020 because i think one of
the points is
i don't want to do this funerally the
idea of fighting for my life
appeals to me if i was on one of those
planes that was flown into the ground or
into a building
i would like the privilege of fighting
back
i would like the privilege of trying to
break into the cockpit
whether or not uh we succeed i don't
like the idea of going to my death
strapped into with my seatbelt knowing
that the uh fastened seat belt sign has
been turned on by terrorists in the
cockpit
you know it's like f the terrorists in
the cockpit let's
talk about the exciting fun part about
taking back two political parties our
universities are press
so that we don't have to be embarrassed
or irritated every four seconds that
people are feeding total garbage
into our um cerebral cortex i mean it's
just i want
i want my mind back i want my country
back i want my children to have a future
this is exciting it's
fun to fight evil fighting evil is a
good
time and so i don't want us to get so
down in the dumps
assume that the republic is in the line
assuming this is an existential crisis
with china
and do you want to sleepwalk through it
well even worse
i mean your point about the being in
your seat is exactly the right one
right i think if you look at the
question correctly
there's a you know if if the plane goes
down
and you charged the cockpit and you
didn't make it
at least it doesn't go down with you
thinking damn i should have it's like
well
i did right yeah i'd rather be bleeding
from a box cutter than
obediently in in a sitting in a in my
seat with a white shirt that has
you know not a speck of blood on it the
point that i'm trying to get at is what
would it take
each one of us as an exogenous event
like if somebody large signed on to this
really big would that change your mind
um if some political person you know
what if what if
ted cruz and i just did an interview
where
ted didn't you know um
didn't come over to my side i didn't
come over to his side but we renewed the
fact that whether we disagree with each
other because we're on opposite sides of
the aisle
we would both repudiate our own wings in
order to
further the american project in tandem
that was a painful and difficult thing
for i think both of us
but huge positive commentary in the
comments everybody's like this is the
discussion we need we need to be able to
see somebody
um who you know is absolutely right to
life
with somebody who's you know strongly
pro-choice in the lingo and both of them
actually able to
admit hey this isn't capturing really
what's going on in embryonic development
this is just some language
okay well what do we do now about this
issue about getting your people
excited and jazzed about the american
project
not kleptocratic not far left not far
right
you get to fight all of the baddies at
once
think about this you've got the extreme
right-wing baddies the ethnonationalists
the people we saw in charlottesville
you've got the extreme left-wing people
who want to just
all cops are bastards tear down all of
the federal buildings f
this stuff you've got the crazy
governors uh
and mayors who are experimenting with
abandoning this stuff you've got people
who are experimenting with militias
you've got kleptocrats trying to put
their children in
positions of power from the center left
and center right we get to fight them
all
that's a terrible thing sort of think
about the bride and the crazy 88s
and kill bill bet on the bride
so at some level you know i'm with
beatrix kiddo and i
you you think you want to be with the
crazy 88 guess again so my feeling about
this is
this is fun fighting badness is fun
get excited and tell us what would it
take for you to view this as the most
romantic positive thing you've ever done
nice so the question i don't know if
noah has already asked it but
the question i think you're looking for
and the way it interfaces with this tool
is you want people obviously people who
are tuned into this are more
likely on board already than not
probably
um but if if you could ask the question
such that people who aren't on board
answer for themselves and people who are
on board answer what they
think would cause people
to george w bush and barack
obama get together and say unity
2020 2024 and 2028 because we need it
now
would that change my mind that this was
an adult grown-up
project who would you need to see defect
who would you need to see as open
support
what would you need to see about names
on ballots
tell us start to confront your fears and
let us know the worst stuff why does
this not feel like a grown-up
project and tell us what it would take
before it felt grown up because to be
honest
what it really takes is an article or
two in the mainstream
very high profile people saying you know
what this is the right thing
so just tell us tell us who those people
are tell us the amount of money that
would need to come in
because let me just tell you you may not
be able to ask for money
this guy needs money if you have
extra money lying around and you're
frustrated about the country not
functioning don't send an amount that's
going to piss off your kids we're not
going to collect some money at the
moment
we're i'm telling you then you're making
a mistake
i don't know what you're doing there
needs to be money somewhere
well there does need to be money uh at
some point um the question is
it comes with constraints it comes with
liberty and
somebody who understands money get brett
out of the loop
and make sure that his team has enough
money that they can do
small things so that this can be done at
a professional level
it doesn't take a huge amount these guys
are running things on a shoestring am i
right you put your own
uh my nephew to work rather uh getting
this whole call up and running
i mean brett's using child labor save
him from being busted by the feds
all right all right um noah do you have
feedback for us
um hi brett hi eric yeah we
right now so we we asked um almost
it looks like over 300 people uh paint
paint is a picture of what could happen
that would
allow you to go whole hog for unity 2020
and um
vast majority of people the most popular
answer already there
give us a candidate uh next most popular
answer
candidates to rally around and
individuals with enough clout to grab
the public detention
um if you guys want to bring this up on
screen it should be the most recent
screen grab
um as i scroll through this list uh
candidates
candidates and ready to go as soon as we
have the candidates
and that's across people from both
parties
all right um and on the earlier
questions about whether or not people
think this is
a moment of a revolutionary magnitude
uh yeah so they're um a little bit
less higher percentage of agreement
around 62 percent
uh people are saying yes but to give you
a sample of the answers uh
62 percent of people of the 259 people
that responded would agree with this
statement
yes feedback loops are heading rapidly
in the wrong direction
one major event away from chaos uh
people from both parties uh agreeing to
that at about
62-63 interesting so at least a lot of
people who
have ears to hear so that such that
they've shown up to
hear this campfire discussion um also
see
one event away from chaos which i think
is actually not
a bad estimate i mean it's a it's a
system that is now held together
by um
self-restraint that there are in fact
certain things that we are not seeing
but could show up at any day which um
would kick things into a very different
phase i suspect
no need i don't think um
all right so where are we time-wise zach
five minutes from an hour all right so
uh we're gonna go for another five
minutes or so are there
things that you think we should uh cover
to wrap this section up and then we'll
take a break and
come back and be more interactive
eric well um i really think that in part
one of the things is is that we should
stop promising people that we can solve
all of their problems
um the issue about how do we know that
you're not a spoiler you guys have said
you know what we were going to take
some measures to make sure that
uh we don't spoil by appealing to both
parties i think that was very clever
uh i think the idea that you can shut
this thing down at will if it appears to
be a genuine threat but to be honest it
needs to be a genuine threat
we should stop bending over backwards to
constantly reaffirm
that don't worry we would never do
anything to upset the apple cart of the
big boys because frankly
i'm not feeding from that apple cart
you're not feeding from that apple
cart most of america is not feeding from
that apple car it's a tiny number of
people who have a broken system working
for them
so you know what we'll do our best try
to make sure
that um you know
in this situation that we take some
precautions to make sure we're not doing
an
obviously screwed up thing but this is a
dire circumstance
and don't expect that everything is
going to be made
uh you know to out of foam rubber so
that nobody can possibly get hurt this
is really
a very dire situation and i think one of
the things is
good job for you guys trying to figure
out how to
assuage some of the risks but you can't
assuage them all
i think with respect to tell us the
candidate names
um the key issue is you know what you're
gonna have to wait
for uh the right moment because
to make this work strategically one of
the reasons i never defined
the intellectual dark web was because
everything that gets defined
gets asked way too many hot specific
questions in an effort to destroy it
so i think it's important that we not
ask too much of of brett's
concept of unity 2020 that we understand
that it can be made artif
arbitrarily rather specific as need be
but that in part we should be log
rolling a little bit more
also i want to know more about the names
is it oprah is it obama
who are the people that you still really
respect
you know when you say names you're
talking about people who would resources
that would change things who is it jon
stewart
tell me you know thomas soule
um who is it that you know if glenn
lowery and john mcwhorter were
talking about this we've got amazing
people
left and right that we've been talking
to and
one of the things that i would say is is
that those of us who are still
living in the legacy system don't ask
for complete consistency from us because
i have to keep one leg in the legacy
world allow us
some freedom of inconsistency if we're
trying to build the new
so i'm not you know 100 on the on board
with unity 2020 but it's the right smart
thing to be doing
to build the boat before the rain
and the issue is whether the rain comes
or not
i think we're going to get very dire
stuff happening right as the republic
really starts to unravel
that is the moment where we have an
opportunity to do something this is what
obama didn't understand in 2008
he let a crisis pass without trying to
get the change during the crisis
so we're going to have a new crisis that
we need people who know how to manage
a crisis in real time and i think that
that's really important and who don't
have
perverse incentives that would prevent
them from managing it properly which
we've seen i think obama may not have
had that many perverse incentives but he
did not know
at the beginning how to handle a
situation which almost nobody gets
there wasn't an instruction manual and
his his tendencies to go back towards
the establishment were too strong
i think it's really important to
recognize that
you know we have ex-presidents would
would george w bush and
barack obama together be your
clue that in fact we've got to reverse
some of the damage of what came later
also
being able to say what we got wrong i'm
on this call in part to say i got
something wrong
it's not easy it's not fun but
part of what we do is we say we got
something wrong in my case what i got
wrong was i didn't realize i was
penalizing
unity 2020 for agency having agency in a
time when everyone else exhibits learned
helplessness and so that's what i'm here
to apologize for
and i think brett if you've failed at
some things in this process
i know you'll be one of the first people
to admit it that's real leadership and
let's not wallow in our mistakes onward
fair enough all right one
uh last question i see a lot of people
who i think are using personality as a
proxy
for danger and
i think it's a terrible mistake i don't
think it's a an accurate calculation at
all but
say more about what you mean what i mean
is i see a lot of people who are very
convinced that
everything has to be put off until trump
is removed from the white house and then
i see a lot of other people who are
just absolutely convinced that uh you
know having biden in the white house
would be
an invitation to chaos and at some level
i think my feeling is i'm not looking at
these people as
people at all they are scenarios right
so there's a scenario in which trump
continues in
the presidency and there's another
scenario in which biden ascends
and the thing is if if you take taste
out of it
right um i don't know which of these
scenarios is more frightening
right it's not a question of the person
there and what you think of them
right i i well i mean the trump scenario
is about
idiosyncratic um
corruption effectively and in the case
of
biden you're talking about systemic
corruption machine
so yeah and so you know of course biden
looks more respectable because he's
the front end of a machine and trump
looks
you know more bizarre because he's
done this drunken master boxing routine
where you know it's like watching
emmanuel augustus it's very hard to hit
a guy who looks crazy
but in fact appears to be playing by
some rule book that you've never
seen so what is the aggregate effect of
being forced to choose between these two
and having a choice between trump
and uh hillary first and then you know
before that it was like jeb and hillary
and
look the big problem is is that you
don't have a future you're excited about
and that's the key issue neither of
these scenarios is an exciting future
we've seen what trump did
for the last four years no we didn't
become nazi germany we didn't become all
sorts of things
the most overblown we're saying but we
did lose
a lot of what it means to be ordinary
americans
had hillary been in in in the white
house i have no doubt
that she would have continued lots of
things that would have caused people
also to feel that they were losing
their i mean the genie coefficient
undoubtedly would have gone up
we would have been more in bed with
china because these people cannot say no
to china and every time they hear
something patriotic they say
nationalistic and jingoistic
so the problem on the left and the
problem on the right
i think once you realize that you don't
have to choose between them
and that you caucus with one or you
caucus with the other but they ain't
your people
suddenly you feel much better about the
world and i think that the most of the
people who are still in the
framework where they see one evil or the
other
are not used to the problem of alliances
i mean
let's be honest we allied ourselves with
stalin to defeat hitler
pretty bitter pill to have to allow
yourself with joseph stalin
on the other hand we went into the cold
war just as soon as we could
you know in this situation look you're
gonna have to sit down with some people
that you're not entirely enthusiastic
about and
the pleasure that comes from doing it is
different
it was great wrapping up with ted cruz
and saying you know what we actually had
a real conversation across an aisle that
didn't become
horrible and neither side just gave up
and you know went over to the other in
in an effort to appear kind it feels
good to fight with your friends who that
you can break bread with and
drink beer with and do whatever uh after
knowing that when all said and done
you're on the same team
we need to get back to that team and we
have a growing threat coming out of
china
in a multi-polar world and it's time to
get back to being the us of a period the
end there is no more
yeah i agree with this the the
conversations with other patriots with
whom you disagree about
issues often feel very good and
i think uh what it's so naughty too it's
like
i can't believe you sat down with that
person right but
yeah and they were awesome and they care
about their country like you do
and they think that you think insane
things which you don't just the way you
think
that they think and saying things that
they don't exactly and so
the one thing is we have a situation
in which something really shocking would
have to happen
in order that we don't end up with one
of these dire scenarios or the other
uh come november amazing
yeah yeah however it's 2020 shocking
things are now
a regular occurrence and this one would
be perfectly in keeping
and the the thing that people don't get
is that it's actually possible
it really just takes people recognizing
that they don't
have to vote for these people i think
that this is a little bit where we run
into trouble
and if if you don't mind you had you're
having me on i'll give a different
perspective
sure it's not possible
if everything happens the way it has
always happened of course not right
just the way powered powered flight
is not going to happen because it's
never happened this is one of these
things
that's not going to have ever happened
until it does
and it has to be the case that either
these parties are going to
sooner or later there's nothing left to
steal you've hollowed the thing out
to such an extent that even the
kleptocracy can't support itself by just
stealing from other people
so we are headed very quickly into some
scenario where we are not going to
recognize our we're going to lose the
republic we thought we had
and if you're excited about that
republic as i am not because
it's intrinsically the project that i
wanted to give my life for
but everything that i ever wanted to do
rests on the idea that there's some
place
to turn in your good work and make sure
that you can get enough resources to go
do some more
and if we lose this thing we're idiots
complete idiots because
we're losing it for the dumbest of
reasons and i really believe brett that
this
at the center it's the fact that we
could no longer trust
the core of these two parties because
they broke faith and that's why the
creepy crazies and the reason that this
is going to work
if it's going to work at all is that
something will happen
which will take this from being a crazy
idea to a non-crazy idea if you remember
the moment in the big short that you
were just referencing
where the hero is sitting down with
goldman sachs he wants to structure a
bet and he says
yes i am trying to bet against you but
it's very important that if you go
bankrupt that i still be able to collect
and at that point he realizes that they
think he's a crazy person
because that seems like a very weird how
could anything ever happen to goldman
sachs well
this is the moment to bet against
goldman sachs and jp morgan only they're
called the democratic party and the
republican party because what's going
wrong
is so much more profound than either of
these things if you thought that those
things
were you know stable and strong then
you're fooled by the fact that somebody
paid for a cheap
layer of marble uh to cover the lobby
yeah it looks like marble yeah but you
can you can
just look at the candidates it's
delivered and you can tell that the
thing has gone completely off the rails
but the other thing is look okay so the
piece of luck arrives
let's say it does things change
we could actually feel positive again
come november company requires a piece
of luck
of course the thing that the thing that
i want your your
skeptical people look you're willing
to trundle into this and that's why
we're doing this because you built
something right
i'm signing on to saying i didn't get
this right
now if i'm more reluctant i haven't had
the other thing happen
in order for this to work something else
almost certainly
has to happen that could be an
endorsement that could be a giant amount
of money coming in
that could be a terrorist attack it
could be a new
health threat it could be anything that
shows up like
i want you to come up with a list if
you're going to have me on
i'm going to task you with the following
bread tell me the catalysts
what if biden and trump both show that
they're not mentally up for the task
because cognate cognitive inventory wise
they just don't have it either
even one of them potentially even one of
them
okay that would be one of these things
um
a more significant walking away from
policing duties in a major city would be
another one
of these things um some sort of
clear hate crime not some sort of
you know thrown together accusation for
which the president
didn't respond sufficiently whatever
whatever the crazy catalysts are you
should make a list of things
that would cause you to say thank god
somebody
built something thank god somebody
created an
alternative i'm not sure whatever i'm
not sure what the point of the list is
obviously you can't make an exhaustive
list because you can't anticipate all
the things that could happen and we just
had a major explosion in beirut lebanon
nobody knows exactly what it means what
if you had an explosion of that size in
an american city and there was a claim
that was credible that it was a
terrorist attack right
what would we do in response you know
i don't know we should anticipate all of
the standard scenarios where things
are destabilized there are deaths that
are incredibly important
there are discoveries that are
incredibly important we could find out
something with elaine maxwell
being in court that implicates huge
swaths of um
our political class whatever these
things are
we should make a list of things that
could be the catalyst so people would
have an idea of that's one of those
things that was
part of the signal that 2020 was ready
to go unity 2020 was ready to go into
high gear
i think the difference between you and
you and myself in this
in this regard is i'm more waiting
on the next piece of
information to arrive than you are and
that is why you were the person building
it and i'm the person saying i really
applaud you for building it
so well i i appreciate that i have to
say
um you know this is this is an awkward
spot to be in
building on the front end for the
straightforward path is one thing
and preparing for the other is uh
front of mind but it is not front of
discussion
i think that the point of i'm building
an arc because there is a sixty 60
chance of a flood is not a dumb
thing if it turns out that x post
there was no flood right
so my point is i don't know what the
probabilities are but the key point is
i want to say to some people i don't
promise you that there's a flood
i don't promise you that this is going
to work i don't promise you anything
that even
vaguely sounds like this i promise you
that it is a smart idea to have
contingency plans
and all of the rich people that i know
are thinking about their own contingency
plans
those of us who cannot afford those
contingency plans need to think about
what we're doing with each other in
order to save this thing because let me
tell you something
i cannot believe how little help we're
getting from our
very established class and i'm hoping
there's somebody out there
who's got executive function coursing
through their veins with tons of cash
who says you know what
i love this country like my i came here
as an immigrant my parents came here as
immigrants i don't know
i want to help
and i and i hope that they force
resources on you i really do
all right well with that i believe we
are going to take
a break of i believe 50
what'd you say zach 15 minutes and then
we will be back and we will
uh interact with you through the
democracy ai
back end that will allow us to find out
what you think
so until 15 minutes from now be well
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
but
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the unity 2020
campfire with
eric weinstein we are now ready to
interact with the audience and to
respond to some feedback that we've
already gotten
um first piece of feedback is that
apparently 70
of people watching feel that
candidates are the most important
question but that given a pair of
candidates that matches the criteria
that we have suggested
that they would support unity 2020 at
the ballot box that's a very encouraging
number
um so there is consensus around the idea
that candidates are
the key issue i should say we are
planning to unveil a process
for nominating candidates uh in the
coming
days that process will be official we
have some unofficial feedback data
collected on this stream that we will
talk to you about
in a moment but essentially we are going
to open up a process that's going to
allow
the unity 2020 community to deliver
suggestions
for candidates from left and right that
they feel have the three characteristics
we are looking for those three
characteristics
being courageous capable
patriots so eric
you able to hear me i can can you hear
me i can hear you
so we have a list of uh names that were
submitted and i confess to you i'm
learning to use this interface and to
understand
what it means i should say i've only
heard two names
floated so far which is uh mcraven and
yang
and that candidates are not particularly
important
to me provided that they simply
be what you say which is patriotic
capable
and courageous courageous and anybody
who's willing to stand alone
uh and try this thing certainly is
courageous and now if they're capable
and if they're patriotic then they'll
get called jingoistic and nationalistic
and then i'll know we're with good
people
so i agree with you um i would vote for
any uh courageous capable patriot even a
single person running for office without
the unity 20
20 20 plan of pairing them would be a
breath of fresh air compared to what
we've been living through
now the reason that we have built the
plan the way we did
with the somebody from the left and
somebody from the right paired together
in a
governance team is that everybody
who contemplates this knows that if they
are anywhere on the
the main spectrum politically that their
interests will be understood by somebody
involved in the decision-making process
and i think
many people would be concerned if their
interests were somehow not understood
even by a courageous capable patriot
even if that's not where you and i fall
out eric
right but let's um take a look at this
list and talk about the people who have
been suggested and
uh what we think of them relative to
those characteristics
and i guess it's also an interesting
question um
whether we understand them to be right
or left or
hard to place so the top name
a top name is maybe not surprisingly
andrew yang and 77 percent
agree that andrew yang would be an
excellent choice
now you know andrew personally sure
um what do you think about about andrew
as a candidate you
wildly in favor i mean my first thought
is is that
i'm wildly in favor of the human being
that is andrew yang and i'm
wildly in favor about getting him away
from the campaign process
that i saw you know there's something
about our process which
deforms everybody and so there was a
weird sense of relief
almost when he left the race after being
brutalized by msnbc and
not getting the air time and all the
usual dirty tricks
so my feeling is is that andrew the
human being is a sparkling wonderful
human
who loves the world his country is
family
sensible he's one of the first people to
square with us which is
education and training and jobs are not
going to get you out of where you are
and that speaks to his courage it speaks
to his acuity
um so i think that andrea is a marvelous
choice
yeah i agree and i also feel like he um
you know you might want somebody who has
a good healthy dose of ego
to be able to fight the battles that a
president has to fight but in his case i
thought
actually um he was very undistorted by
ego i don't know what his relationship
is with it but i felt certain that if
for example
it turned out that there was a
compelling argument against universal
basic income
but that there was some other way to do
it like participation income
that he would be wide open to hearing
about how it might be done better
and there would be no part of him that
would uh shut down the idea because it
wasn't
the one that made him famous yeah he and
i disagree about ubi to an extent just
the way i disagree with you to some
extent about
about the unity 2020. um but the key
point is somebody
i could definitely work with and you
know
again he's not attached to the
instantiations he's attached to the idea
of getting sense
back in our political process yep great
all right
second on the list is tulsi
so presumably that's tulsi gabbard i
can't name another tulsi who might have
risen to the top of this list
tulsi tulsi made the point to me
that she said you know i didn't
understand what this process was when i
signed up for it
and i believe that tulsi has
a lot of presidential temperament
whatever my disagreements with
her art might be on foreign policy i'm
not even positive that i understand her
positions well enough
she is somebody who is one to watch and
she's somebody who i think i would take
orders from
and would allow to lead me into battle
if
if it called for that and i think that
another
wise choice of somebody who could
benefit from not being put through this
incredible farce yeah i agree um there
are things about
policy stuff that of course worry me a
little bit but in general i had the
sense of a very
solid human being interestingly she
seems to
resonate better with people on the right
than on the left i find even though i
don't see any reason to think that she
actually
is right of center what do you think i
think that the fact is is that
well first of all if the right wants to
embrace a capable
uh woman of color
hell yes i mean i think it just gives
you an idea that the right isn't what
many people claim the right to be
i think that she's a you know as a
mutual friend of ours
uh mike brown would have said she's a
command and control babe
she's uh hard as nails soft when she
needs to be she's this
person who combines so many traits and
shows
that in fact um i think
one thing is is that she appeals to a
hierarchical nature
of somebody who's not so driven by ego
that
you're you're following them is to i
think she's really behaved egoless
relative to me every time i've
interacted with her and so my personal
interactions with tulsi have been
sparkling fantastic interested in all of
my criticisms
slow to anger not defensive
a fighter willing to go up against the
dnc
so my feeling about it is despite my
foreign policy
concerns uh just the way foreign policy
is her signature issue and andrew's is
ubi i don't need to agree with them on
their signature issues either
yup agreed okay so she
reached uh 70 67 percent
uh approval in this straw poll
and let's see next on the list is
mcraven of course maybe not surprising
given that the
idea was launched with them as a
prototype ticket
how much do you know about mcraven not
enough
not enough you have a thought about
whether he fits the bill or
again you know my feeling about this is
if you asked me for all of my
uh wish list items uh when i looked in
my feelings is that there's there are
things to find that are not
perfectly aligned with me who the hell
cares yeah who the hell
cares who the hell cares i agree i will
say
if you're not familiar with mcraven it
is well worth looking into some of his
public speeches and things he's written
i find them
actually quite compelling um
he gave a recent talk at uh i guess it's
the navy war college
on uh leadership it's quite good um
anyway i think people who don't know him
would be
well served by just getting a sense for
the man's uh his temperament his
approach his sense of humor it's all
i think very positive by the way the
first the first two are really disliked
by the democratic party i hope that he
is really disliked by the republican
party
because being dead on arrival to one of
your own parties would seem to be a
prerequisite at the moment
well actually if we can just point out
with uh with yang and gabbard
there's a sense in which um as they left
the race and apparently
signed whatever pledge it is to uh not
get in the way of
the ascendant joe biden um
i understand the instinct to be a good
soldier and i understand also
potentially the idea that if you behave
yourself long enough the
dnc would let you run but i have to say
as a long-time observer of the dnc
there's no way the dnc will let either
of those people
attain power unless they agree not to
use it so unless they change or the dnc
changes yeah so dead on arrival is a
huge plus
it's a it's a prerequisite and if i
could reach them with one piece of
information i think they need to have
it's that
the dnc is using you and it's not your
friend
okay fourth on the list so mcraven
was 59 approved
um next on the list is joe rogan
what do you think joe shuts me down
whenever i bring this up
he does huh he's got a beautiful life
he's been oh no
he shouldn't do it because it's good for
joe because it wouldn't be
look my point is is that if the world
were calling joe rogan's name
i'm not saying that he would not answer
the door
but when when i'm calling his name and
saying we have to get involved
i think he has an instinct which is
politics be too crazy
yes although you know i mean again it
would be pointless
patriotism i'm happy to talk to tulsi
and andrew i don't know mcraven i'm not
going to call joe
and suggest this to him because he's
already told me
we're we're not we're not calling joe
we're just talking you
me and uh you know seven thousand of our
closest friends
right behind his back okay good right
well exactly in front of his back
actually
um all right so uh
okay so joe is pretty clearly left even
if the left
or elements of the left want to portray
him as right
he's definitely not there's nothing
about him that's right i find
he hunts elk oh right his elk hunting
nobody he he he's old school he's
he's pre left right with his bow hunting
oh i see with the bow hunting that makes
it better
yeah okay um
now interesting um
he only gets 24 approval so these are
not in order then because
okay there's something about them that's
not clear to me the order there's
they're nearly in order
but okay scoot back to the names
okay next on the list crenshaw
kimberly crenshaw i believe it's dan
crenshaw oh dan crenshaw there's a huge
difference between a dan and a kimberly
crenshaw
uh not unless they want there to be a
huge
difference yes well interesting well
since kimberly came up with
intersectionality
i would think that you would probably
want one
i would imagine so yeah i was actually
speaking with dan crenshaw
this morning um it's the second time
i've had an extended
conversation with him and the funny
thing
is that uh for people who are
quite far apart politically we find very
little to disagree over
i suspect we would disagree over the
standard things
that uh liberals and conservatives
disagree with which is how close
to the particular desirable end state
the country is as a liberal i probably
think we're farther away and he probably
thinks
we're closer to it at the moment but in
terms of the world
that we want to see it's amazing how
little difference there turns out to be
in in our case do you have much sense of
the man
uh i have a sense of a good man who's
tough as nails
uh with a patriotic spirit
who is more american than he is
republican
um and again
uh you know this is just a clear sign
bret that you and i are
part of the far right extreme i like him
yes well welcome to it um yeah all right
cool
yeah there is something interesting too
just um
but just your earlier point i should say
it's very hard to care about
whether or not you think the tulips
should be uh yellow
or or pink when you're being
attacked in pearl harbor you know and so
the the fact is i look forward to my
disagreements with dan crenshaw
tulsi gabbard uh mcraven yang
but my point is is that mostly what this
strikes me is uh
the patriotic crew rather than party
totally agree and i i would put it
slightly differently which is that
um our system is so distorted by
corruption
that the number of things that we should
just obviously do for the public's
well-being
is huge before you get to the stuff over
which we might actually differ
right just simply governing in the
public's interest would be such a
a break from recent history that i can't
even imagine it
right what a day that would be wow yeah
hey could be january
all right next on the list
is lowry i assume this is glenn lowry
who is being advanced
now glenn is could be annie lowry
ezra klein's wife i'm gonna assume it's
glenn i read her recent piece i i can't
say
i would be all that favorable to seeing
her in a position of power
well her quote is progress is messy so i
think not
right okay so let's assume glenn lowry
uh
you know glenn yeah what do you think of
him uh
i like him a lot i don't know him like
you do i think i've had a phone call
with him and that's been
i've never met him but my sense of it is
that he's
brilliant tough and uh
radical individualism which i love
yeah he's uh razor sharp
has no cowardice that i've seen
whatsoever he just shoots from the hip
and uh he's also pretty accurate yeah
and he's just unbearably likable
and he's one of you every so often you
meet one of these people and it's like
hard to imagine that anybody dislikes
him
um i find him he could be a little rough
he'll be a little rough he can be a
little gruff
but even that is kind of endearing is
the thing the g
before rough good exactly um
all right next jon stewart
i have a lot of positive feelings about
jon stewart from years ago
he did something that really bothered me
which is that he did a march on
washington
where he refused to make it about
anything
and so we've now had these multiple
marches that aren't really about
anything
um nevertheless at the moment
sure yep if you're detecting a theme
it's like
anyone reasonable yeah anyone
courageous competent patriotic i'll have
a
double helping of that yeah that's a
good list all right keep going
yeah all right so i it's funny by the
way all these people i slightly disagree
with
is there anybody you don't like slightly
disagree seems
to me like it's likely to be the least
amount of disagreement there's probably
no
people i agree with to a frighteningly
high order and i do agree that once you
have booked a tremendous amount of
agreement that your
your fighting takes a different
character um which is that the
the small things really really matter um
but what i'm
seeing is basically just doesn't doesn't
even matter yes
any and other than trump biden hell yes
if i could if i could wave wands yep
all right yeah we would uh expelliarmus
our way right to that
okay um next on the list actually
can i see the data jocko is the next one
on the list can you uh
scoot this over so i can see how that
breaks down so i am not waking up at
four o'clock every morning to do
calisthenics
kettlebells he would wake up at four
o'clock so you know that i don't have
time right exactly no no no i know jack
so jocko gets uh
39 agreement from
trump supporters and 22 from biden
supporters
so i guess i'm a little unclear on what
the implications are about how the
question was asked because
does that mean that only 22 percent of
people
who consider themselves would would-be
biden supporters would support jocko if
he was one of a pair
right i can't imagine that actually i
don't know but jocko's pretty
pretty uh straightforward no-nonsense
he's got a huge heart a guy who
has never had a cowardly day in his life
um loves his country and
uh you know certainly again whatever my
difference is with jocko
irrelevant so i i wanna just in passing
point out that we have a number of these
individuals
who are special forces trained
who show up in our political
and academic landscape and
i think it's trying to tell us something
i'm not sure exactly what but
relationship with the unforgiving
if you have a relationship with
something that is not mediated by other
humans
that punishes you when you get things
wrong whether that's investing
whether that's rock climbing whether
that's uh
hunting special forces building
machine buildings building buildings
carpentry any of these things
solving partial differential equations
right anything in which it's not
mediated by social approval but i guess
my point would be there's something
about um
i think there's something about the
special forces that is generating
a different style of intellectual
and anyway they're free
they're free and they have something to
prove well think about the word elite
we don't mind there was an elite unit
that was deployed oh thank god we have
elite units
we're not angry at our elite special
forces guys and the idea is that they
walk around with a certain amount of
swagger
because they're doing the lord's work um
you know
and at some level i think that that's
part of the whole thing that the the
intellectual
warrior we want people to have the
ability to go to war
but that not the need to go to war nor
the pleasure in war
yeah and i think that there's something
very noble
about the philosopher warrior
yep i i like it i think that's that's
the right uh
category for the thing i'm that's what
i'm hunting for here also i should point
out that andrew yang skateboards and
tulsi plays the ukulele which is much
harder than most people imagine
especially while you surf so everybody
here
is doing something that is mediated by a
direct connection to reality
[Music]
and i i i also think that
[Music]
these people have humility and have
uh strength to project and those things
sort of a rare to getting in general
together and it's one of the reasons
that they're so likable agreed
um so so far have you seen anybody on
this list or heard anybody on this list
who you think fails on any of the three
criteria no keep going
we'll get there yeah all right next one
things are going to get dicey
uh tucker carlson tucker carlson
17 approval overall can you scoot over
so i can see
33 percent against by would-be trump
supporters
six percent would be biden supporters
yeah that's going to be problem
problematic for a lot of people because
i think tucker carlson gets sloppy on
some stuff
or at least he did and then
i i think that he's a he's a complicated
case for many different reasons
and so he's the first one where i sort
of have a slightly different
feeling i believe he's patriotic what do
you have competent
and courageous yep he's all of those
things
i think that one of the problems though
is is that he's a little bit sloppy
when it comes to um
things that don't sound good um like
i think there was an issue with
immigration where he used the word dirty
but it
dirty wasn't necessarily used about
immigrants being dirty
but maybe coming from dirty countries or
whatever this sloppiness
issue is going to make the left hate him
in large measure on the other hand i
think that your point
is is that he's a much more complicated
object than
the left of center portrayal of him
and that people should take the time to
figure out what they're really upset
about as opposed to what they've been
told they should be really upset about i
know tucker slightly
he was princely in my interactions with
him
i've never done his show i've been sort
of avoiding
doing more things you know right of
center because i feel like
the left of center has a game where they
won't give you any
place to do your thing so if you accept
any right wing invitations then you
become like owned by the right
but i think that tucker is an
interesting case that people need to
understand much better and he was one of
the few people who was willing
to cover the evergreen situation which
is the precursor for a lot of what's
collapsing
uh and have you on so and
yes and i will also say a john stewart
tucker carlson matchup for president and
vice president
would be awesome it would be very
entertaining and i actually
i think i agree with mike they might
even get along
i suspect they would i mean you know
i've seen tucker carlson
maybe i haven't seen but i've heard him
interact with glenn greenwald
i certainly know that you saw that you
saw the
the john stewart blowing up crossfire
ah but that this is the other point i
wanted to make is that my sense
watching carlson over many years i used
to
absolutely detest him in the crossfire
era which i actually told him right i
told him that he used to be my example
of
um a weak man who wears a bow tie
uh as a bully and he uh
he laughed it off he said you know you
should see my inbox
is literally what he said but in any
case i said
the thing that he said to me um i said
is i said
you don't want me on your show because
i'm just gonna say that fox news
is a propaganda network he says no that
would be great
well so i have the sense that he's very
much in motion and that he is now
you know when i tune into his nightly
rants there's always
20 of it that i find hard to take
yeah but there's 80 percent of it where
i actually feel like he's speaking to
issues that the left is supposed to be
speaking to when nobody else is like
class warfare he does a much better job
than most people well you can ann
coulter's like the only person who
supports me when i say we need a
deep and biting labor shortage that has
our ceos howling in pain to last for 50
years
who supports that you would think it
would be the party
of mother jones who you think would be
the party of labor no
it's ann coulter everything is flipped
because the democrats flipped on labor
well i'm going to
sidestep ann coulter here and just say
that the thing about carlson
is a he appears
maybe in part um you know in recent
years hearing from people like us but
he is aware of an honorable left
which he is now championing um i think
if he's been moving if i read him
correctly he actually knows that the
left has to do a job
in order for america to work that the
tension
between the left viewpoint and the right
viewpoint is important
and if the left fails that it
is the problem the problem we're going
to have is that tucker carlson
in the minds of many people immediately
points to
racist beyond the pale white nationalist
because people have invested
in summing him up in those terms and his
sloppiness in a few places
has made that easier than it should be
given that i don't think it's actually
true
right i think that he's a very different
sort of an object
however you know all those bubba the
love sponge phone calls when he was
calling in and
yucking it up i mean the fact is is that
he's he's a wild man
a little bit and you know that wild man
persona
can get him into trouble when it comes
to saying a lot of things that cross
through your mind but he's an
interesting person
who has largely been misunderstood
misclassified
he has done things that are going to
make it very tough to have him as a
bipartisan this be the first one where i
would say
that's that sounds like a bridge too far
yeah well i think it is a bridge too far
based on uh these data at least on the
basis that he's so wildly polarizing
yep okay next one um
interesting thomas soul
how old uh i would i knew you were gonna
say that i think far too old by your
normal criteria
i would say like bernie sanders i see no
evidence of cognitive decline
in you know he's done fewer appearances
but his appearances are razor sharp
still
nonetheless there is a question about
whether we should be
electing people this old and of course
you know how old is he i don't know
offhand
all right but the thing is
he'd be a natural as an advisor
i mean i want him in i want him in the
process
i don't think i want him as my president
yep i i want to i want to see people
turning towards people in their 40s and
50s and even 30s more
yep i'm sorry to say it i mean 60s would
have been okay but i'm
sick to death of the septuagenarian plus
impulse as if as as if as if we've
always done that
yeah what how old is he 90 according to
the internet
yeah if he's he's too old he's too old
but a fine advisor he would make but you
know like noam chomsky is still with it
so it's not
no no reflection on in being too
diminished right it's just
it's actually real yeah actuarial okay
so uh let's just look at the data on him
twenty four percent so if you'd run with
tom lehrer i dropped my
i'll drop my objection just um just
awesomeness yeah so uh 27
approval amongst would-be trump voters
18 percent
uh in would-be biden voters that's
that's good he's much less polarizing
that's great
okay scoot back over to the names
oh now it gets really dicey
uh bret with one t that's gotta be me
and then you're right there eric with a
c
so um look in light of the fact that
those show up here now are you ready to
call joe and get him to do it
first of all i clearly lack courage
and competence so really we're going on
my patriotism
so in my case i must decline
because of my my cowardice and my uh
lack of competency however uh
i've sort of noticed that uh when we get
into a jam
like if i were to get into a power boat
and we
the motor stopped working i would hope
to be in there with you
because for some reason you learned how
to do all this stuff that i didn't learn
how to do when we were growing up
so i would i would put brett weinstein
uh
above eric weinstein by far
um i wouldn't but uh let's just say
we can do better america we can do
better we can do better america okay
good um oh but pretty good i don't think
either one of us has ever sought power
i've definitely sought to have our
voices amplified i've never sought power
yep don't think i want it so let's take
a look at those numbers just because
it's interesting
39 percent overall approval on me
36 on you
well hold on i think 43
uh i think weird okay 43
approval for me amongst would-be trump
voters 33
biden voters for you
it is 35 trump voters 29
would be biden voters so these numbers
don't tell the complete story there's
some missing number here
for one thing i i do believe that
a fair number of conservatives really
vote conservative to stop
madness on the left and a fair number of
left-of-center voters vote to stop sort
of
uh meanness and and evil greed
on the on on the right and that one of
the interesting things is if somebody
else were handling your problem with the
other side
what would it free you up to be for
because
i think that a lot of what the right
really values in you brett is is that
they know that whatever brand of left
you are it's not lying about science or
nature or
data it's not about going along with a
group you're an
anti-collectivist and i would say that
i am more anti-collectivist even than
you i think that ein rand was
insufficiently individualistic
so you know in part i i do think that
they are
correctly picking up on you in you that
you are the guy
on the left who would fight the thing
that is terrifying them which is sort of
this mayor jenny
mayor wheeler phenomena uh
well okay good i'd like to think that's
what people are responding to
well because you know george bridges at
evergreen state college was the
precursor of mayor jenny
and mayor wheeler and in some ways joe
biden
and in some ways joe biden stand down
the police that would be a
terrifying thing to do we're giving the
army the weak off
because we don't like guns they are mean
all right um next on the list
interesting a different turn
condoleezza rice
totally unenthusiastic about it i hear
she plays amazing piano
i hear that she's smart as can be
probably
patriotic i want to know that she's not
patriotic to that class of people
too many entanglements uh
not wildly enthusiastic however i could
i could have a dinner with her and
change my mind in an instant
yeah i think that's a that's a good
analysis i i sort of have the same sense
um you know i've i hear mitt romney's
name bubble up my sense is the last time
i checked in with mitt romney
he doesn't qualify but it doesn't mean
he stopped that outsourcing stuff
yes he was part of the thing that broke
the bonds
that we feel to our fellow countrymen
and and as
you know i think brett the simplest
thing to say is that you and i come from
a patriotic
left and the modern left is
anti-patriotic
very often uh you know it is against
anything being american anything being
you know market driven and so coming
from a
market-oriented patriotic left
i think that that's just that's a huge
difference in the case of condoleezza
rice
uh i i worry that she's too much a part
of that
kind of group of people who divvied up
who cut us all up and served us to each
other
um the same thing is true with mitt
romney the way in which he made his
money
was in part by breaking the bonds that
we feel towards each other so
i'm happy to find out that they've moved
on they want to repudiate
previous positions i am not
enthusiastic without further
clarification
yeah again who am i i'm just one guy who
happens to be on the campfire
right but no i think this is a good
analysis and i you know i think in a lot
of these cases
you would want to check in with where
they are not under the
former constraints but the same concerns
the other issue is is that if i was
going to
vote non-trump non-biden you know would
i want condoleezza rice with somebody
who i
felt more certain of yeah i
i again i'm feeling desperate i'm
willing to swing
at some pretty far out pitches under
normal circumstances to get rid of this
ridiculous choice that i'm having shoved
down my throat
yeah all right well we've worked our way
pretty far down the list here
i think maybe what'd you say
um i'm being told there's another slide
with interesting data
i'm not sure what i'm looking at i'm
just going to repeat to people
um for those of you in brett's camp who
are you know
already you know very clear in unity
2020
maybe this is the right question for
people who are more in my camp which is
unity curious my feeling about this
is i really don't care quite as much
the whole point of abstracting this was
to avoid getting into the particulars
of individual names and whether they had
something in their
past or it's to focus us on the idea of
get me the hell out of here
right arnold schwarzenegger's famous
line which i think everyone needs
to to repeat is come with me if you want
to live
right it doesn't get better than that
yeah i like it um all right is there
anything that you
want uh feedback on here or do you feel
like we've
um pretty much is that you've done a
pretty good job
i think people need to hear let me let
me just give you some brotherly advice
um the whole principle of the slow clap
right is is that you need people to
reify what you've done and what you're
trying to do
and if there's one person who doesn't
want to reify what you're doing it's me
i hate i hate having to say this but
it's the right thing and
and you're you were right and i didn't
get it and
again i'm not wildly unity 2020 but i'm
unity curious i care about unity 2024
unique 2028
we need to alert people to how badly
this thing is rigged
if you step outside of the normal
boundaries of the democratic party for
example if we hold a debate
that is a long form that gives people
huge ability to
respond you are having those candidates
break with the party
if you don't if you want to challenge
the super delegate system you're asking
people to break with the party
people don't understand how constrained
this is we used to have the league of
women voters for example conducting
debates
i don't know how we now throw it to here
cnn
you get this one in new york times you
get this one and npr you can participate
and the ideas
it's like f that stuff what we need is
extraordinarily
different procedures long-form
podcasting
is the new thing that has taken over the
intellectual interest of people who have
real
concerns and issues with the world they
want to figure things out
the idea that we're still doing this in
short form and that andrew
yang and tulsi gabbard are getting like
a tiny number
of minutes compared to joe biden and
elizabeth warren and all this stuff
you know i also think that elizabeth
warren could have been a much better
candidate had she not been subjected to
the process it's corrupting
everyone you either want to be relevant
and therefore corrupt
or you want to have integrity and
therefore irrelevant and that's
something
that's a feature not a bug to
from getting through the primaries how
can we trust you if you have any
integrity left at the end of the process
how do we know that you're not going to
stab
us insiders in the back and actually
govern the country
and so the idea effectively is we need
to make sure
everybody is corrupt and has blood on
their hands so that we can
we can remove anyone it will because
these these individuals are the
equipment
of a process and i also think that we
just have to recognize like i want
things that are bad for the donor
classes
and we can't expect a process in which
the donor classes
are necessary to produce things that are
hostile to the donor classes like
do you think that the donor classes who
contribute because of the carried
interest exemption from on income taxes
right do you think that those people are
going to turn around carry
turn against carried interest you know
the fund managers and things
there's no way that that's going to
happen and so what we need to do is to
recognize
that what we need is dead on arrival
ideas
the kind of ideas that have been dead on
arrival
contain many bad ideas but they also
contain all of our good ideas
any good idea is dead on arrival and
that has to do with the fact that rent
seeking has taken over
we need to get back to doing what
americans do
which is finding vaccines and and
launching and landing rockets
and and and creating software that
nobody's ever seen before or probing the
the heart of uh you know condensed
matter whatever it is
we need to get back to being a smart
country
the the the vacation in the land of
stupid must
come to an end and there's so much
stupid in left
right and center that i think one of the
great opportunities here is to oppose
all the stupidity at once and at the
moment you probably have signed on to
some stupidity because the other guy's
stupidity is driving you crazy in my
case i can't imagine
walking away from policing duties i
can't think about anything else when i
find
out that people are walking away from
policing in part because my own family
you heather and the kids were
subjected to this we ran an experiment
where the president
of evergreen state college stood down
his own police
so that people could roam around looking
for you f that stuff
now does that mean that i've lost track
of the fact
that uh i'm left of center no but you're
experimenting with stuff that is so dumb
and then the idea is that somebody says
well you surely you don't mean
abolishing the police and
that's what it says we don't want nomo
police
okay what the hell does that mean you're
saying it in black vernacular to make it
absolutely
clear and honestly there are so many
other communities
that require the police for their
protection if you don't want to
experiment with the police you have a
problem
because where the whether the police are
are terrifying to all of us and they are
terrifying to all of us
my particular bug bearer there is you
cannot
suspend policing you're talking about
anarchy armageddon whatever that thing
is so expensive to me
that i weirdly can't see anything else
if you suddenly removed that i could
start talking about single-payer i could
start talking about abortion rights
i could start talking about all sorts of
things about genie coefficients
but at the moment i'm so focused on the
idea of
who is going to stand up to these mayors
and governors who want to stand down the
police
i can't think straight now that normally
would push me into the arms of a donald
trump
except i can't obviously and i can't go
to biden
and so that that issue about a
supersaturated environment
which is somebody get me the hell out of
here
that's really what 20 is about and if
your particular
bug bear is like kids in cages and
that's your thing
you know it's like i can't believe how
horrible trump is and biden is going to
deliver me from that or the supreme
court
my god look it's wonderful to worry
about the supreme court that imagines a
functioning republic decades into the
future
i'm really not seeing that that's a
guarantee anymore
and so thank you brett for trying this
for not succumbing to learn helplessness
for not listening to me when i told you
this was a
crazy idea um it's going to need some
luck
and so in part people should just just
get ready
be if you can't fully sign on yet at
least
be unity curious and wait for the luck
because in 2020 you'll never know what
might happen next and brett
i really do think you should anticipate
all of the signs that the universe
is telling you to go for it with unity
2020. i think you're waiting for an
event
i don't know what its name is but i know
what the flavor is people are going to
be shocked to their core
and they're going to say isn't there
something to deliver us from these two
men
and when people start asking that
question
then you have a mercutio moment and a
plague on both of these houses but
mercutio doesn't die in a scenario which
you planned ahead so good luck
well thank you eric that was a beautiful
way to end this
unity curious is a great concept and i
hope that lots of people will discover
that
uh that that's where they are
all right so thanks everyone for joining
us
and um we will see you on the next
unity campfire be well be well everyone
[Music]
foreign